why did Michael Shanks leave
Stargate one of the many times he died
he left for over a year why welcome to S
check your SciFi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel recently on dial the gate with
David Reed David Reed by the way is a
walking Encyclopedia of Stargate the man
loves Stargate to a level that is almost
creepy he just loves Stargate I mean I
love Stargate but that man loves
Stargate um and he recently had a
interview with Michael Shanks the
premiere was the final episode in the
third season of the dial The Gates
series it's a marvelous marvelous
interview and the full link is in the
description please go and check it out
i' love listening to Michael shank's
talk he has such energy and he really
does cover things like his relationship
with Richard Dean
Anderson uh Rick is not the easiest guy
to work with on a regular day-to-day
basis what happened when his appendix
nearly burst and so I'm like going like
you can't just cut me I said I said
maybe I'll go home and um and if I feel
worse I'll come back but if I I feel
better I'll you know then then we'll do
s or if I feel worse we'll do surgery
but if not I'll just go home and he goes
no and I'm like why he goes because
you'll die I went oh oh oh I didn't I
didn't know that there things I didn't
know about appendicitis so um I guess
they they
quickly like within an hour I was under
the knife and lots of lots of insights
about what it was like to work on
Stargate and the extras are getting
soaked there was almost an extra Revolt
they almost because they weren't getting
they were weren't they wanted to shoot
French hours to get us through which
means no lunch break
so the extras were cold wet hungry and
ready to revolt against the production
um we're were who we were who were so
excited we were like bringing our
umbrellas over to them because we're
like oh we just want you to be happy
blah blah blah but in the meantime um
yeah I think the film became unusable
for that entire day so talk about a
disaster the Titanic in the making it's
like you break the bottle on the side
and the ship sinks right is we're going
oh my God have we just made the big
mistake of Our Lives we we we thought
like are we cursed or something but he
also talked
about the elephant in the room why did
he leave now I've read several articles
over the years and really to be honest
there's lots of different versions to
this story he fell out with the writers
apparently even though that actually
probably is true to a degree and I think
Michael Shanks would even admit that he
may be left under a little bit of a
Cloud but it was not the big drama that
lots of people would like you to suggest
when they're writing their little
articles for the
internet and and so so discussing the
option of coming back I was like you
know what yeah we can work this out he
did feel that the character wasn't
really going anywhere that he wasn't
really doing anything with it it's true
that he wanted to have far more action
with the character and he wanted to
develop the character more and it
stopped being a James sper impression
that's where you know where I think that
that the switch happened where the the
James sper interpretation got really put
in a box and it moved on to being a lot
more like myself and um uh which was
again a lot easier to play than
continuing to go back to that um that uh
ageold uh characterization and for the
place I was at in life it also made
sense as well so
he really wanted to develop it and he
just didn't feel like it was going
anywhere he was always the nice Canadian
to the O'Neal's rough American and I
don't know I think he was finding it a
little bit
boring it's true that before he actually
joined Stargate he had done several
Shakespearean roles things like aell Etc
and in 1998 he actually did appear as
Hamlet not an easy role and actually his
appearance in Hamlet did sort of push
into the schedule of Stargate a little
bit and he had to get permission to sort
of continue to do it now nicely Brad
Wright
Etc sort of got around it but even then
in 1998 it's true that Michael Shanks
had his eye on other projects He was
even thinking about pulling out then so
when he did leave he did do a couple of
other projects none of them were good he
did a couple of movies I've written them
down so I've never watched them Escape
From Mars in 1999 looks terrible
suspicious River in
2000 now that had Molly Parker in it who
is a marvelous actress but you actually
read the synopsis it sounds seriously
dodgy and actually Michael Shanks played
ball cap man and Donis Davis was in it
our Hammond and he played man in like
colored shirt or something
so I can only imagine that somebody from
Stargate was like written it or produced
it or something like they they just like
got friends in to just like appear in
the background but it was not a big part
um when he when he had called me up I
was I was in uh South Africa shooting a
terrible movie um and um uh uh he called
me to to talk about uh the idea of me
coming back to the show and and I was in
this this um head space where I was
in one of the most impoverished areas
I'd ever been in uh filming with um uh
Shanty you know just out my window when
I'm talking to him on the phone and I'm
like you know any problems that I had
are are are seemingly you know minute in
comparison to the real world problems
that I'm just looking at Michael shank's
actually talks here about how he was
filming one of these movies in Africa
and he really saw one of the most
poverty driven places on Earth these are
the places on the planet where you have
to walk to get water you don't have a
flushing toilet it's a hole in the floor
that's type of poverty where actually
starving to death is a real life day
today
concern forget about your mobile phone
being low on battery what do you do when
you've got no food to feed your children
that kind of place Michael Shanks is
talking about how he really did reeval
evaluate his life and when he got the
phone call from Stargate to say look
Richard Dean Anderson is stepping back
you have the opportunity to allow the
character to really grow because Rick
was taking a step back from from uh
filming he wanted to spend more time
with Wy and and um you know uh take less
time in the show and and so he wasn't
going to be there as much and so they
needed somebody to step in a needed to
be part of the action sequences more
when I was totally open to that because
I've been kind of campaigning for that a
little bit um before I left the show and
uh and so you know they wanted the
character more action oriented I was
like sounds good to me you know yeah and
become far more of a central character
within the series we are going to allow
you to become edgy it really was going
to allow him to bring more Michael
Shanks into the role and as I say less
of a James sper impression I think the
the cynicism um or the S sarcasm if if
you will that um Eed out of Daniel that
sounded Jack like is just
Michael he talked about his relationship
with RDA you've seen the clip and they
obviously did have a bit of a LoveHate
relationship in a way now I think I'm
over exaggerating the hate bit because
he obviously has great affection for him
like we all do but as he says he was not
always the easiest person in the world
to work with and I can imagine
professional actors would pull their
hair out at Richard Dean Anderson at
times but I don't think that was really
a reason why he left it was really just
because Michael Shanks is a proper actor
he wanted his character to develop and
it wasn't developing as quickly or in
the way he hoped so he looked for other
roles when he maybe was disappointed by
those roles and Stargate returned the
call remembering that he never really
properly left as an ascended being he
appeared a couple of times in some very
important episodes so he was still in
and around the project but when they
called and asked him to come back
full-time and to really fill some of the
Gap Left Behind as Richard Dean Anderson
sort of stepped back a little bit from
the
show it allowed his character to grow
massively and then when you get somebody
like Claudia Black coming into the
series it allowed the character to grow
again in a different way I actually
think him stepping away from the show
was probably the best thing for him it
allowed him to re-evaluate the situation
it allowed people like Brad Wright to
re-evaluate the situation and I think it
made for a better character development
in the long run so that is why Michael
Shanks left Stargate briefly I actually
have loads of respect for Michael Shanks
I think he's just one of those people
that is honest I think he actually
thinks about things before he says it
and I think he has a massive energy I
absolutely adored watching this
interview and please go over watch it in
full and don't forget to subscribe to
dial the gate for more interviews if you
are a fan of Stargate and you're not
subscribed to dial the gate then I have
to question how much you really love it
and if you are new to my channel don't
forget to subscribe we're big sci-fi
fans over here ourselves hit the Bell
notification do all those buttony things
it really supports the channel also
don't forget to go to
patreon.com where most of our new videos
appear first and you get to see them
without the adverts you lucky bunnies
also go to
c.co which is our dedicated website
where we do articles based on most of
our videos and we try to add a little
bit more detail for you to digest so go
and check it out as always please stay
safe and I'll see you next
time
[Music]